you're critical of the United States I'm
guessing a year ago at the Economic Club
of New York do you take your criticism
away for these meetings because the u.s.
is simply doing better look at four
percent gdp last quarter do you give the
United States a victory lap it's clearly
one of the bright spots you know when I
look at the advanced economies the US
pops out as you know in a much better
condition and the UK does as well but
clearly on the investment and
infrastructure front more needs to be
done why can't I think all of my viewers
my listeners readers worldwide are so
frustrated by this why can't we budget
infrastructure that clearly puts
blue-collar workers as we say in America
to work there's an immediate cash on
cash benefit why can't we jumpstart
infrastructure I think the more of us
shout infrastructure is needed the more
of us face this poorly maintained
bridges and roads around the planet not
just in the United States not just in
Washington DC where frankly riding a
bike is becoming difficult but also in
the low income countries and developing
countries where the the power is needed
were there obstacles to transportation
where they are bottlenecks in emerging
market economies such as India for
instance it has to happen and as you
said it would be good in the short term
and it could support the medium-term
growth potential as well